un homme à terre sans défense
l'acharnement est impitoyable les images
sont violentes
le 3 mars 1991 il ya tout juste 30 ans
rené king un jeune afro-américain et
tabassé par quatre policiers blancs
après un excès de vitesse et un délit de
fuite
la scène est filmée par un vidéaste
amateur georges holiday j'ai pris ma
caméra je me suis précipité au balcon le
temps que j'arrive il était déjà en
train de frapper le mec à chaque fois
qu'il essayait de se relever une prenait
un coup de matraque
la vidéo fait très vite le tour des
télés américaines et choquent l'opinion
publique
des manifestations ont lieu aux états
unis en présence de personnalités comme
les acteurs alec baldwin et kim basinger
le tabassage de rené king devient une
affaire nationale voire d'état le
président george bush réagi au scandale
c'est insoutenable de voir ses hommes
que lombard est rien à mon sens ne peut
justifier tout cela c'est monstrueux
après des mois d'enquêté les quatre
policiers sont jugés à los angeles en
mars 1992 dans le jury dit blanc un
asiatique et un hispanique
les quatre policiers sont acquittés
c'est l'élément déclencheur des émeutes
raciales dans la cité des anges
il y à lui les images sur la caméra les
preuves sont bien là mais on s'y
attendait quand même à ce verdict
pillage coups de feu incendie pendant
six jours los angeles s'embrase
notamment dans le quartier de south
central où la communauté noire est très
importante
l'état d'urgence est décrété des
militaires et la garde nationale sont
appelés en renfort le bilan des émeutes
est lourd plus de 50 morts et des
centaines de blessés la nuit dernière
quatre mille cadres nationaux ont
investi la ville quartier par quartier
véhicules blindés hélicoptères un
déploiement de force sans précédent qui
ne semble pas particulièrement
impressionné des émeutiers qui sont
parfois armés
face à cette pression populaire les
quatre policiers sont rejugés devant une
cour fédérale en avril 1993
deux d'entre eux sont condamnés à deux
ans et demi de prison
les deux autres acquittés à los angeles
l'heure est au soulagement
les policiers ne peut plus cacher
derrière leur ainsi abuser des gens
espérons que ce message ira plus loin
que los angeles dans toute l'amérique
jusqu alors jamais une vidéo amateur n'a
eu un tel retentissement dans la
dénonciation de violences policières
la sphère rené king a marqué un tournant
[Musique]